i'm joined now by the composer and
theater impresario
lord lloyd webber and also by madeleine
lloyd weather and uh lloyd webber and
i'm very pleased to see you
both uh and i want to talk about the
theater royal in just a moment but first
um lord lloyd webber i mean since
freedom
so-called freedom day theater
performances are being cancelled
across the country um from your
cinderella to community
productions do you fear as one producer
says that the the theater industry is
being
pinged into oblivion
i fear that it's very very difficult for
any theater show of any size
to be able to operate with the current
uh
rules uh in the in the case of
cinderella we had somebody who was
asymptomatic
had been double jabbed uh who was caught
by our very rigorous testing
regime that we have ourselves on the way
into the theater
as a precaution he was tested positive
as a precaution
i cancelled the shows last saturday
and then although every other person in
the cast
uh what was negative and tested twice
since that time
uh negative pcr tests by anybody who'd
come close to him
all negative uh under the current rules
we
would not have been able to reopen so we
decided that we would just have to
close for the time being and um
hopefully reopen again
when these rules uh are supposed to
change on august the 16th
but um with this government uh who you
know you never know
uh i mean for some reason uh theater
doesn't seem to
count as having key people or key
workers
whereas uh of course uh the indian
football team
of course had key players and key
workers so
um we just never ever get a crack of the
whip from this government
right so i mean it's also now hitting
supermarkets the police
railways do you think that
self-isolation should be scrapped
immediately for those who have had two
jabs rather than waiting until
mid-august
well i would have thought that if you'd
had two jabs and
if you'd allowed the the time lapse for
them to be effective which i believe is
sort of two weeks
um you know there is no real reason
why why you would not be able to
allow say a theater to operate normally
i don't i don't see any reason
one of the most important things and
this is a point that i make time and
time and time again
is the importance of ventilation in
these buildings and what we've seen
in the last few months and let's face it
we have seen it
and we all know that we have been into
gardens
where markings have been put up uh and
where you
find poorly ventilated marquis or people
then pinch points going to
pub lose or whatever you know we've seen
all of this we've seen the scenes at
wembley we've seen
the scenes you know throughout this
whole of the euros
um and and yet and yet uh theaters
with and certainly in talking of my
theaters no recycled air whatsoever
um state of the art air conditioning and
and and air
handling um we we somehow are lumped
together
with you know every other like
nightclubs and everything we are not
we're not the same
theatergoers are a law-abiding bunch you
know we
i would insist that our theater goers
continue to wear masks
um and uh there's not one
but you know there's not a lot more one
could really say do you think frankly in
despair of this government
right i mean do you think the government
risks losing public consent
with the way that it's going i mean
people are perfectly willing
are they to to turn up to theaters for
instance
well they are uh i mean all i can say is
is that
um i don't think i've ever had so many
people
uh get in touch with me to say that they
had never
never believed that there would be a
conservative government who would behave
this way towards such an
important sector of the arts the
commercial theater has had no
support from the uh with the the
cultural recovery fund to speak of at
all it's less than one percent of it
and a project like this at the theater
rotary lane which is a
a massive undercat undertaking it it's
it's we've had craftsmen from every area
employed here we've done massive massive
massive work
but has one government minister showed
today no
okay so i mean you just the last word on
this my wife madeline
yes just the last word on this you don't
think then that you will be
your some of your crew cast will be
exempted from this or exempt
from this well it would be a
would be a wonderful thought but i can't
see very much uh
likelihood of that happening but what i
don't understand is is that you know
they
bang on and on and on and they provide
insurance for films and this and the
other
they don't understand that a really
successful theater production
can make far more revenue for uh
the government than a film ever can i i
mean we're standing in the
theater all day lane where the disney
corporation are presenting frozen
i got a very very helpful email from
tom schumacher who is the president of
the theatrical division of disney
worldwide
pointing out that the lion king has
outgrossed in the theater and just in
the theater not the film just the
theater has outgrossed
the entire harry potter franchise
the entire franchise we've got a couple
of minutes the government doesn't get
this
no well look let me lady madeline i mean
the
theater royal is back or we'll soon be
back fingers crossed pandemic
permitting um it's a positive story tell
us what what you've done to the theater
well the theater isn't actually
dependent on on the show
what we've tried to do is to make this
amazing space of
incredible architecture and art open to
the public
every single day whether there's a show
on or not people can come to
drury lane they can have a cocktail they
can have a cake they can have coffee
they can
have a bite to eat and you don't need a
theater ticket
so that is why we're opening most of the
theater the front of house theater
tomorrow and we're doing our open day
today
to show that we've actually tried to
create a a sort of
five-star hotel feel inside a theater
and that's been our ambition and we've
remodeled the auditorium where frozen's
coming in
next month but i'd like people actually
to enjoy the theater
experience in front of house and the
foyer without actually having to go into
the theater
itself and so that's been our ambition
and um
let's see how it goes when we open to
the public tomorrow yeah well look i
wish you
um luck on that and just a final word i
mean where do you stand then
um lord we're on covered passports do
you think this will be a way
of going forward for people who have had
two vaccines
i think it will have to be i think
inevitably as in america
as they now insisting on broadway
it does look to me as if that's the
future and we're we're set up to do this
but we
also would provide natural flow tests
for people who haven't been vaccinated
on the way in
um i mean i i do worry a little bit i
mean with
cinderella for example we're getting a
very young audience
uh and i don't want to see them excluded
but i think the way things are moving
uh which is not necessarily my opinion
but i think the way things are moving
i think you'll find that vaccine
passports are going to become more and
more
uh necessary and well more and more
um the only way that anybody would be
allowed to come into space is
you know like theaters